and even if you think of
germany for example as being kind of the
third largest
economy in the world it's neck and neck
with japan right now
germany is the economy that it has
become because its manufacturing machine
has largely become dependent upon china
right so it wouldn't be where it is
right now if it wasn't for that
symbiotic relationship in between its
industrial base
and the needs of its main customer if
you think about it that way
but on more on a geopolitical level
you know the imf right now is involved
in
bailing out i want to say 74 countries
worldwide and you know i get people who
follow me closely know that if
if you call this the corona virus
recession i just
my fangs come out because it's not it
is a black swan economic event that
exposed
a lot of leverage right and
in many cases a lot of these countries
that are being bailed out by the
imf were aided and abetted and becoming
as over leveraged as they are
via chinese banks and i doubt in a
million years
that china figured it was going to end
this way that they were going to be
under a microscope
in the year 2020 being told by world
authorities to stand down
and that they cannot collect on their
debts because these countries are on
their knees
in many ways because so has the quiet
colonization
gone awry and are we paying enough
attention to this because this is
this was a part of their grand plan
right well i mean so
bring the world bank into it i don't
know if you remember but world bank
basically signed up
to in perpetuity giving them a billion
dollars giving the chinese a billion
dollars
because of just like every just about
every other international institution
the world bank's been
taken over by the chinese no i don't
think they were expecting this
that being said you still have hundreds
of billions of dollars
making their way into china through the
ipos that are
going on in hong kong x-punk just did a
billion and a half ipo on the new york
stock exchange despite having stolen
technology from apple and tesla
and then you've got the chinese bond
market is booming
so so it's not just about the imf
wall street london berlin they're all
sending money to china and that's what's
kind of feeding this thing so i don't
think it's stopped
quite yet the door because the door
hasn't shut yet
and that's really the thing if this belt
and road initiative
was to rely solely on the currency that
the chinese communist party could create
that i think does less than two percent
of transactions globally correct even
today
um they would it they would that would
fall apart in a heartbeat what they need
is hard currency because hard currency
gets them the raw materials and
resources that allows them to continue
on the belt and road initiative so this
is our big problem
and it's one of those things where i
keep saying you know the first thing you
do is you find yourself in the bottom of
a hole
is to stop digging right and yet
and and we know the power and the lure
of investment banking fees uh
but when you think when you think about
what's happened in hong kong
and the situation and how it has
evolved why on earth would
they even risk cutting off
such an important international conduit
to their own liquidity
well that i mean that's a good question
i don't think that they do
find that at risk because here you have
a country where there's effectively been
a
you know one country two system policy
that clearly
said no we're going to have one country
one system
we have said state department has said
you're no longer sufficiently autonomous
but yet how is the fed in the treasury
erected the hong kong monetary authority
still produces a hong kong dollar still
exchanges it
for the u.s dollar so in effect
the chinese communist party has two
currencies
they have what is considered you know a
freely exchangeable currency in the hong
kong dollar
this is how they get hard currency
and then when you when it gets into the
mainland
exchange by uh by the people's bank of
china for
renminbi and then they take their the
communist party takes their cut
the money goes wherever the communist
party wants it to go
you know when you raise money on the new
york stock exchange it goes to that
company
if a chinese company raises money on the
new york stock exchange it goes to the
people's bank of china
who controls the people's bank of china
right
so that that kind of brings me to
where chinese authorities want to go
next
right now there's there are very few
options
the provinces inside the country
are very weak still it is just the big
three
exporting monsters that are doing well
the same way we talk about there being a
k-shaped recovery here in the united
states
there's an equal k-shaped recovery in
china right now
and they've got a serious issue with
unemployment that we of course don't
know about but we do know about it
what they're doing is going back to
their very old playbook they're
pouring money into infrastructure
spending
they finally stopped buying copper but
they've been buying up iron ore
and this is what they did this is what
they did in the 90s this is what they
did in the aftermath of the
financial crisis but is this just a stop
gap measure where and what does it imply
for
australia and chile and brazil and
other countries that seriously rely
on china to support their economies
when we know that india is not a viable
next place to go in terms of
a demographically attractive country
that needs
to come out of the third world era in
terms of its own infrastructure but
india's not there yet so what are the
implications for the countries that have
relied on china
for decades now and where does china
really want to be spending its money
today so the belt and road initiative i
think is
is a good indicator of where they're
going
and i think what they're trying to do is
essentially connect resources to
productive capacity to markets
and that's going to be tightly
integrated with
the belt and road initiative which has a
maritime
component it has a landward component
and it has a digital component
and so the idea is essentially to
connect these countries that have the
resources
to the productive capacity of china to
offload some of that quebec conduct
productive capacity particularly in low
value added products in those countries
and create its you know basically an
economic sphere of influence
that is um paired with a social and
political
um system that they are comfortable with
and so what they what's happening is you
know because of what america is doing in
terms of
resetting the way it deals with china
and it's doing so along with its allies
and partners
essentially the democracies are
beginning to come together like they did
during the cold war and they were very
tightly integrated in fact
there was just a um a report
talking about this idea of a technology
d10
right the democracies 10 coming together
for artificial intelligence 5g
is it was in there there's a report
coming out that talks about this
and has to do with 5g and security
that's going to be the democracies what
what china has in mind is
the emerging market economies and the
other authoritarian regimes so we're
talking about middle east we're talking
about africa
talking about latin america we're
talking about central asia and you know
the
the the four horsemen russia iran north
korea and china
so that is what they have in mind and so
this idea of a digital currency goes
right along with half
the um undersea cables that huawei has
laid with a digital
silk road the building of 5g networks
the ability to control the populations
using
technology that silicon valley built all
of this
is meant to have this arrangement
where kind of china's at the core
and it and it provides the capital via
you know it's it's the the renminbi
which will be part
so it is a closed you know financial
system but it's extending that firewall
for that financial system
to the countries in its orbit it did the
so in the beginning
through bilateral currency exchanges
which
you know it also did with democracies
those are going to go away
so those currency exchanges are going to
exist and and most likely what i'm
guessing with
the introduction of a digital currency
is that they're going to try to
basically create this
this you know greater greater firewall
with it with a digital currency that
allows this
kind of economic activity in the way
that they've
thought about which is the people in
charge stay in charge
and everybody else are subjects well it
sounds like they're going after
places where they can
where they can take control effectively
right um
it truly sounds like you're talking
about well the word you used before this
is
a bifurcated type of future that's being
envisioned
between the developed countries and the
less developed countries
it was fascinating to me that australia
went so far
as to head a coalition of countries
demanding an independent inquiry into
the origins of the chronovirus
given that china has done so very much
for australia but i think their their
first recession in 30 years
and the fact that there's so much debt
that's been built up and some of the
buildings that the chinese have come in
and built
are flammable and so i visited australia
for some time
i think they're realizing that it that
it was a deal that necessarily
wasn't necessarily made with their ally
[Music]
you